you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] like hearing
about this and seeing the stuff that
Gabby is going through I don't know her
personally but that [ __ ] is
heartbreaking to watch this human being
who's you know worked really hard to get
where she's at to have it all taken away
because her mental state isn't the way
that it is or maybe it was always like
this but we don't really know their
personal lives what kind of [ __ ]
psychopath
looks at this as an opportune moment to
[ __ ] tear another human being down in
five four three two one Hello everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we're once again in that
new studio with Studio 71 baby let's go
was a robin couch say hello
hello
so
I was just talking about this with Robin
um and our buddy Tom actually just
messaged me this he goes have you heard
of this thing with uh Gabby Hannah I saw
a little bit of it yeah yeah so
I have never met Gabby Hannah but that
girl hates me
okay that girl [ __ ] hates me
um I don't hate her the reason why so
years ago just to give you guys a little
backstory and I've talked about this in
the podcast way back in the day but for
new listeners you'll hear the story
again just to give you context
so
I did this video with Justin and this is
during the time that Justin and I were
doing these fake videos of us fighting
together right
it was just a really fun social
experiment because I was making fun of
how people fake Vlogs for views right so
Justin I would get all these fights and
I forgot to tell people that was fake
very important detail yeah and so I I
only knew recently because there was
like a few comments coming up being like
you're so ungrateful for this person
who's an amazing director he was just
trying to guide you and I was like oh
[ __ ] it's fake guys well you guys were
like practicing your acting for [ __ ]
yeah because you guys fight a lot in the
film exactly I was like oh this was for
the film guys I'm sorry I forgot to
listen because I I remember like
um back at the studio
um downtown that JK had you were sharing
an office there and I came in and I
heard you and Justin screaming at each
other yeah but then over time I was like
wait it's the same words yeah like oh
you guys are practicing lines that's how
good the acting was baby and so it
really stemmed from that and um
well in this thing too that was just
tough I recorded this conversation that
we had and we were talking about Gabby
Hannah because she was stealing stand-up
comedy bits from Bill Burr and you know
and she was on using it as her Vlog as
it was her own content yeah and listen I
understand that in West content creators
like for example I've done like Dave
Chappelle jokes and Kevin Hart jokes but
it was in the know of everybody knowing
I'm doing a Dave Chappelle Kevin Hart
joke yeah I'm not saying it's mine right
everybody knows it because if I go oh my
God I'm not doing and oh my God they're
like oh he's doing a Kevin Hart thing
and that's why it's funny right right
she was just saying that this is my
material
this is a problem right and I was like
and at this time too and even now I got
fed up with like content like young
content creators stealing [ __ ] from
people and it still happens now and now
it's becoming more and more acceptable
and that's what we were talking about so
we had a mutual friend that contacted me
and he goes hey
um so Gabby hit me up and she's pissed
she's like you know who's this [ __ ]
fat [ __ ] that's just you know talking
[ __ ] all this other stuff like he's like
tell him to take that video down if he's
your friend and he he calls he goes I'm
just telling you this but don't take the
video down I'm just doing my part to let
you know but I know you're not gonna do
it I was like of course not and I was
like also too just let her know number
one you did it own up to it yeah that's
all that it is I'm not telling you that
you're untalented Because by the way I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody says if
you look at her earlier advice they were
[ __ ] funny and she really did set a
style of like a lot of people bit her
style because of how funny and unique it
was and I thought that she was really
good you know people could argue without
she's untalented I don't think so I even
saw this video of her a worse
is it is going to go into the subject of
what happened with her where um she was
like in a bathtub where she was singing
a song that she wrote and it was just
her doing an acapella and it looked kind
of crazy but I was like hey this sounds
kind of fire she's [ __ ] talented it's
just we understand like it's hard to do
every day on Vine yeah she's she's
pretty [ __ ] talented I don't I really
don't care what other people I don't
know about her personally right I only
spoke about stuff that was uh put out
publicly problematic problematic yeah
but in terms of her Talent as a musician
I think she's pretty [ __ ] dope right
uh as a content creator I thought she
was really funny and very very creative
but in the recent years
um she started showing signs that she
was a little you know she needed help
yeah um
um you're talking uh mentally yes
mentally yeah not like with their math
homework yes
she did a tutor that's why she was
better she was like a Cree you didn't
help me out at all but he
um yeah mentally she was deaf there was
definitely things that that was
happening to her that was [ __ ] insane
and
um I don't know her personally don't and
nobody wants to be reached out by
somebody that they don't [ __ ] know
yeah how how [ __ ] annoying is that
right yeah uh I haven't heard about her
in a long time and I've just been seeing
stuff and hearing stuff here and there
but once again I don't talk about [ __ ]
about people like that especially if
they don't have a personal connection to
me or I don't really know them right and
if I didn't say to their face I'm not
gonna stay behind their back yeah
I start seeing this stuff
uh recently so our buddy Tom Texas have
you seen this thing with Gabby had it
where she was having like a manic
episode where she you believe she was
like the Messiah she was like a god
whatever whatnot on Tick Tock right yeah
yeah she posted like a hundred videos in
like four hours or some [ __ ] yeah how
[ __ ] frightening right and when I see
that [ __ ] it bothers me and we've seen
this with other content creators who
have lost their mind and they're still
you know they think that they're better
but you could see it in their eyes that
they're not people like Yousef you know
Fouseytube he had his manic episode as
well losing his [ __ ] mind yeah and
now I see it with Gabby and I see it
with all these content creators who Rose
to stardom and fame really really fast
yeah and their mental stuff isn't really
checked along the way they don't have a
lot of good people around them to help
them out
or maybe that because of their behaviors
the people left well like when you're
growing and stuff and stuff people will
say yo you're the [ __ ] you're the best
you're awesome and then
um those comment comments don't come
anymore then maybe somewhere in your
head you might think oh I'm the opposite
I'm the I'm shitty I'm you know bad I'm
this and that I'm not good anymore right
yeah and so
there was this other guy who's like a
tick tock Creator or some [ __ ] and
he's just like streaming all the stuff
or whatever and we just talked about
that kid who had that um the Reddit a
AMA which is going to come after this
video anyways but you'll you'll listen
to that podcast but this [ __ ]
found out where she lived right and in
guise of pretending like oh I'm doing
this to help her because I want to help
her out he doesn't know her finds out
where she lives asked if he could use
her bathroom and she starts going on a
you know a rant about like you know the
you know the crazy psychotic state that
she's in
uh to him but he's recording her home
um all this other [ __ ] saying that he's
trying to help her out but really he's
just doing it for views so he could gain
clout oh my God this person is literally
the trashiest [ __ ] human being ever
you're the [ __ ] staying online I kid you
[ __ ] not and I'm saying this like I'm
not okay I
not to get into any legal trouble I feel
if I ever see him I'ma smash his [ __ ]
teeth in yeah once again I know Gabby
Hannah hates me I don't know her like
that but the fact that you could exploit
another human being's like mental
breakdown for your own [ __ ] come up
is insane and you're trash if you follow
a [ __ ] for that reason you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] like hearing about this
and seeing the stuff that Gabby is going
through I don't know her personally but
that [ __ ] is heartbreaking to watch this
human being who was you know work really
hard to get where she's at to have it
all taken away because her mental state
isn't the way that it is or maybe it was
always like this but we don't really
know their personal lives what kind of
[ __ ] psychopath
looks at this as an opportune moment to
[ __ ] tear another human being down
for their own game it's just
exploitation it's it's probably the the
most [ __ ] up part about social media
is like they see something like a TMZ
and they think they can be the paparazzi
of social media like literally nope nope
this is nope this is no yeah it's so
real it's frightening to me like it was
that same experience that we had with
Black Mirror we you know these were this
is like stuff that it's kind of
exaggerated it's very hyperbolic but
it's not anymore it's real [ __ ] this is
actually happening and everybody's just
[ __ ] okay with it because the excuse
behind it is you know oh why are you
trying to [ __ ] kill my vibe it's like
what the [ __ ] is happening with this
world who's real Viber are you killing
though yeah in order for you to get your
Vibe who what are you taking away from
you know
watching this [ __ ] was insane man and
having been around other content
creators who have gone through these
like weird crazy psychosis stuff it's
being an Entertainer isn't natural yeah
having everybody had their eyes on you
isn't natural having to always worry
about oh if I say this what will happen
well you know this this whole
entertainment industry is so [ __ ]
sickening and gross it is one of the
biggest reasons why I don't like being a
part of this and I just had a
conversation with a buddy this morning
because he was texting me about stuff
because I tweeted this [ __ ] the other
day where I was like
it would be a person saying oh I can't
believe this [ __ ] actor is they're
trash they're the worst person I've ever
met I know all these stories and they're
telling me this stuff about them and
they book something and the next day
they go proud of you sis you're killing
it dude your acting was amazing
what in the [ __ ] is going on the part
you're part of the [ __ ] problem
you're feeding into this psychosis and
the other day these people who I know
they're acquaintances but I don't really
know like that but you know we DM each
other now and then I'm calling them out
of them dming them I'm like the [ __ ] is
this literally last week you told me
that this person is trash and they're
like nah like but you know I think
they're still no [ __ ] you bro I was like
you know the next time I see you I'm
gonna [ __ ] give you [ __ ] and they're
just laughing about it but you know I
will give you [ __ ] like especially if
you're in my vicinity this is how we are
yeah this is how I am I've always been
like this yeah but that type of behavior
is [ __ ] stupid if you dislike
somebody you don't like what they are
you better stick to those guns because
you're openly trashing this person
behind their back yeah right but then
all of a sudden when you see this
opportunity to ride their coattails
because they book something big and then
you're like this person's [ __ ]
amazing you are [ __ ] trash you're
worse than that person yeah you're way
worse than that person and this is just
another version of that [ __ ] yeah it's
[ __ ] weird man I mean yeah the we
were talking about you know that they'll
come out later earlier about
um the idea of trauma porn and
you know that was
in a way like uh what I what I loved
about the movie nope was that it was
turning trauma porn into a horror film
about our behaviors towards it when we
see something that is so [ __ ]
terrible we need to film it you know now
in a sense I'm guilty of that too
because I have [ __ ] ton of videos of my
store that I filmed because I we had
security cameras and stuff and for me to
cope with it was to turn that into
I guess in a sense entertainment
um and then after watching nope I was
like huh oh [ __ ] you know was that the
best way to deal with it yeah you know
was that the best way to respect what
was going on around me I had these
moments too I remember uh specifically
when we were living in K-Town and you
know every now and then you see some
crazy [ __ ] and I was like oh this is
some crazy [ __ ] maybe I should record
this because I would never record
anything yeah because I'm so enraptured
in the moment because I think for me
instead of recording it I want to
remember this moment so I could tell it
in stand-up jokes or whatever but there
was almost dude that was smoking crack
and he got up stood up on a bus bench
squatted and he started [ __ ] on the
bench yeah and I recorded it and I was
like this might be funny and then I
looked back and I was like this is
actually not funny at all this is
discussed this is disgusting like feel
this guy's insane like I feel bad and I
looked at myself I was kind of like
disgusted at myself I'm like why did you
think that it was appropriate for you to
record this yeah or in in any sense like
think that you were going to post this
and I had those moments and I feel like
people don't had that that thing in
their head anymore because it's like oh
[ __ ] this is going to get views this is
going to get likes this is going to get
comments whether it's holy [ __ ] or oh ew
disgusting or whatever it's the
engagement that we're looking for and a
lot of us have to come to the
realization of what social media is
doing to us the most hilarious take that
I saw and it was like something that was
circulating around was um what's his
face
um
the Paul brother [ __ ] Logan so why am
I [ __ ] I should know his [ __ ] He's
talked about him so many times but Logan
Paul was saying that how nope was a bad
movie like he thought it was dumb he
doesn't get it it's like of course you
know it's about you yeah dude uh was he
is he the guy that went to the Japanese
Forest yeah yeah it's like it's
literally about you which is so funny
it's hot crazy ironic that he doesn't
understand what the point of the film is
is about exploitive behaviors yeah
that's well maybe not him now so much
but that was you and it's kind of insane
so it just goes back to the thing oh you
are really detached from this world and
I don't even think when I was looking
back at it I was like oh maybe it might
be a publicity thing for the podcast it
wasn't I could look at this if he's
being very sincere I'm like oh [ __ ] he
actually thought it was a really bad
movie yeah because I think it probably
speaks to a quality about himself that
he hates about that's unlike yeah yeah
so he's like oh this is dumb it's like
no this is this is or was you it's your
own personal Black Mirror [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean this is I saw a clip of
him too on um some other podcast I
forget which one one it is but um he was
talking about how
before that whole uh Japanese Forest
thing um he was good friends with The
Rock they were on like a DM basis they
were making content together you know
and then he said when all that [ __ ] in
Japan happened the rock asked me to take
all our videos down that we had together
or he didn't his publicist did yeah and
then he had no contact with him and then
recently uh he just did uh I don't know
if it was WrestleMania or yeah yeah yeah
yeah and like I saw some of the clips
like damn he's a dude he's a wrestler
Hey listen I always give respect but
respect is due whether I actually I
don't even dislike I don't know him like
that uh that [ __ ] was [ __ ] dope Logan
yeah when you jumped off the top rope to
the table I don't care what nobody said
[ __ ] talented as [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] dweeb this fool is talented as
[ __ ] and he said that he caught a DM
from The Rock again he's like hey I just
want to say he said he didn't read it he
just left it on red didn't respond and
his his reasoning was if you weren't
there for me at my lowest then I don't
want to celebrate with you at my highest
it's like bro you filmed a [ __ ] dead
body nobody should have talked to you
you can't [ __ ] see that you really
think the rock should be like hey man
I'm here by your side you did something
Despicable disgusting disgusting and you
can only think about yourself you know
highest level of narcissism also too
he's not your friend
he and my your friend my friend am I
your friend yeah he's not your friend
he's not to your friend okay you are not
a body body it was a business move right
yeah you have a big following he has a
big following he was trying to grow his
social media presence you guys were
using each other that's how this
Hollywood [ __ ] works you eh no
friend
the idea that he thought oh my god this
is my best friend yeah [ __ ] dweeb no
you guys weren't friends yes you're on
Dia there are plenty of people who are
in the space who are on DM bases we're
not friends we get along yeah we're kind
of cool but let me tell you something
the moment I talk [ __ ] about Shane you
see they disappeared real fast yeah
I get it everyone's want to say yeah I
know David so hey I know the rock
because of their DM bases but then like
dude like in reality are they really
there for you are they really your
friends you know I I talked about that
one YouTuber
um you wanted to meet all these other
YouTubers at a party specifically she
wanted to meet Khalif yeah you know
because she wanted him to act in one of
her stuff
oh yeah okay we'll see yeah and as soon
as she [ __ ] met Khalif and did a
video together unfriended me and all
that [ __ ] like was I a little butt hurt
sure but what she we really ever there
for each other no I always kind of saw
it as like oh she just really wanted me
to start making videos like the way I
was doing for you but yeah we were
roommates we were homies when we first
met in Seattle you flew up to Seattle we
did the Kim Jong-un let's get we [ __ ]
connected like that yeah I and we're
also friends yeah we're friends we're
really good friends yeah but then I I
felt like she just wanted me to like
make her videos for her like I did yours
but it was just like no we're not even
like coal writing we're not even in a
collaborative State at all yeah you know
and I could walk past that it didn't
wreck me you know like that but it it
showed me true colors of of this [ __ ]
business you know like yeah there's a at
that time there was a lot of like
gorgeous women who were sweet talking me
but I'm realizing oh they wanted me to
help them make content of course and
this is how it works and I'm pretty sure
when I fall into that trap yeah like I
don't know this girl [ __ ] personally
right but I'm pretty sure she's in a
position now where she's probably people
have done the same to her and now she's
might be even regretting it now but
people need all these type of life
experience like I said I make no
judgment on her I don't really [ __ ]
know her that's still [ __ ] up but I I
kid you [ __ ] not the same people who
who have done this type of behavior to
other people they're telling other
people that they hate people who do this
right but it's you man like I value
myself so much more than me being a
content creator I think I can be a great
friend to you too but you don't want
that yeah you just want what I can do
for you yeah you know it's like the
version of of like the the Instagram
girl with big tits like they just want
to [ __ ] them and leave them right right
and at the time too I feel like for a
lot of video people they would see a
video person like oh man like I want
them to make videos like do you know who
I am hey [ __ ] do you know who I
am I do this for a living yeah like I
could do this for a company and get paid
well I don't have to do this for you
right like this is a job for me as well
I don't think people realize too because
I was working for a pretty big uh social
media company uh content creation
company at that time they're paying me
very well yeah you know I told you about
that guy too like I did a video with uh
Joseph Vincent and a few of his other
friends and because he liked it so much
he sent me an email he's like dude great
job on the video because I did this for
JV but he was like I want you to do my
next video and I'm willing to pay you
fifty dollars
are you [ __ ] crazy I was making that
in an hour at that point you know shut
the [ __ ] up Jason Chan why do you do
this
okay it wasn't him I'm kidding yeah so
so that's the thing like people have
this [ __ ] up idea of like what this
space is and holy [ __ ] do people love
exploiting one another yeah yeah it's
just a really bad I mean listen we we
love film you know I I still love
entertainment because of a lot of the
stuff that you get out of this right
um you get people like Jordan peel yeah
you know who's an amazing Creator like
every talk I don't understand him like
how the [ __ ] do you do key and peel and
do some of the best movies I've ever
seen in my life like horror films you
did comedy and now you're doing horror
like the most horrific like two real
like it's a little too real yeah this
his type of horror films kind of stick
with you for the rest of your life yeah
and it's just like the
that's what I also like about the art I
know like for for I have a lot of gripes
about the space because I think I'm
griping about it from a person who is a
part of entertainment but not really
right because I I don't care for it as
much you're independent yeah I'm very
independent so when people try to tell
me oh you shouldn't say this or do this
because it's going to [ __ ] up your
opportunities I'm like what
opportunities like what up I don't care
about these opportunities if it comes to
my lap or it comes because I've done
great things and they're like hey I want
you to be a part of this project [ __ ]
yeah I'm going to be the hardest worker
on set and I'm going to show you what my
value and worth is but if you're
dangling this carrot in front of my face
you won't do this if you don't say this
I will whip out my dick and you can
[ __ ] suck it I could give a [ __ ] less
yeah I have a very very this is what
people don't you're protecting your
dignity yeah I don't have a lot of time
on this earth like all of us don't we
have a very finite time on this Earth no
matter how great you do things unless
you're somebody who's like Kobe Bryant
who has created such an amazing Legacy
rest in peace my man yeah I'll be
forgotten the next day I can only care
about the things that I do on this Earth
that I care about that I have to [ __ ]
live with right and they're like well
you could be a millionaire I don't give
a [ __ ] I can't take any of that [ __ ]
with me I'm going to die and in fact I
might even die a month from now two
months from now three months a year I
don't [ __ ] know I just have to be
able to live with my choices and that's
the weird thing about uh LA and the
creative space right because you guys
are in the same space they think you
guys wear the same shoes yeah that
you're thinking the same way they do
it's like dude are you serious you're
gonna lose you know sponsorship it's
like you but you're not chasing that pie
yeah you know it's like that you can do
that and that's perfectly fine but once
again I have seen so many times over and
over
what it has done to people and it goes
back to Gabby Hannah it goes back to to
Yousef
um
you know what the funny [ __ ] thing is
too is like I got I got message the
other day because
um I told the story about like you have
to realize too and I've said this a
million times if you hear this crazy
story that I'm telling you about and I
give you names these aren't the names of
the people unless it's Jason Chen
right like I I'll say a name like oh
this guy Peter and like I can't believe
you out of that person who's supposed to
be your friend I say a last name I
didn't say a last name it's also his
name's not Peter also this person's not
my friend yeah like there's no way I'm
gonna give you information especially
that's that damning about people who
aren't in the entertainment space I'll
even tell something that's like oh this
person one knows entertainment they're
probably not even an entertainment the
the story and the heart and the things
that happen are true all the details are
different because I care about these
people's personal lives because I told
the story about somebody who had like a
psychosis thing and they're like oh my
God I can't believe he's out of KevJumba
Kev Jumbo's not my friend I don't know
him you [ __ ] idiot and they're like
oh but uh but you told the story about
this other guy and it's like who says a
guy it could have been a girl yeah you
don't [ __ ] know I'm not that dumb you
[ __ ] idiots because in it this person
to DM me recently was
every time I filter through it's because
I guess Kev Jumba had a Resurgence he
came back yeah as a Dragon Ball Z
character he's blonde and [ __ ] he even
he's got the Derek Brunson look he's
like shaved but blonde why is everybody
dying in her blonde now [ __ ] I don't
know 90s are coming back yeah and I get
like kev's doing like music and [ __ ] now
yeah let's do a rap it's [ __ ]
Terrible by the way but my opinion my
opinion yeah you you may like it
pause
but
respect
I just didn't I do not like it at all
only because in his case and once again
this is just my opinion about it he
sounds like he's trying to do something
that's not inherently him and it's
something that he probably likes and he
enjoys but he doesn't have a knack or a
talent for it he's not a part of that
culture right like there's somebody who
for example like uh what's that
Indonesian kid rich Brian yeah Rich
Brian right you could tell this kid
loves hip-hop like he the Cadence and
everything that he says and all the
stuff that he's doing about his music is
he inherently loves that culture a lot
you could tell Kev might like hip-hop or
whatever or he might like the culture or
whatever whatnot but now like the way
that he dresses the shaved head the
blonde [ __ ] the music that he's doing
it's like damn it's like you're trying
to fit a square into a circle like you
got to find your Niche but there was a
weird thing back in the early 2010s
though of YouTube where all these
Chinese kids were doing sea walking on
YouTube because he's so Chinese walking
that's what it is it's Chinese [ __ ]
and that was Kev right that was Kev he
was doing seawalk videos I bet you a
bunch of Crips are like these
[ __ ]
this is some real [ __ ] you know but like
I said that's just my opinion about it
like I don't I don't know him personally
I did a video with him a while back but
kind of and I'm pretty sure a lot of
people can sense this too like you see
somebody
and I support him trying new [ __ ] I
support everybody's trying things
failing and doing new things that you
really enjoy I'm not talking about the
enjoyment I'm talking about my opinion
about his music because now he's in an
artist space so when you put art for the
public to see the art the public is the
judge I'm also a part of that public so
I thought I'm like I try to listen to
his music and listen I gave it a good go
because to me
in terms of a content creator he was
actually one of my favorites
um because he was just creative yeah he
had his own style his own Flair and
that's what I really liked about him
Kev was always Kev and when Kev got into
acting he was actually one of the better
Asian American actors out there yeah so
when you talk about how I feel about uh
Kevin Wu I respect this [ __ ] a
lot but your music sucks good Jesus
Christ like the the topics that you're
talking about even when he curses it's
not the fact that the clean-cut person
is a country that makes me feel weird it
sounds like he doesn't even feel
comfortable cursing right so it's like
bro you did such a good thing of Paving
your own way and having your own
identity in the comedy YouTube space the
vlogging space
that was so uniquely you that made you
special
find that in music now too right find
what makes you special about music it's
like uh MC Hammer doing gangster rap
yeah but you know over time people just
forgot about the the gangster rap part
and they still remember him for you know
can't touch this you know and I feel
like that's my how I feel about
something yeah he still has his legacy
oh yeah dude Kevin Kevin is also also
reminds me a lot of um
someone who I really [ __ ] with but I
didn't like his videos at the time
Ryan Higa is my
top three or four five content creators
of all time this dude though I didn't
find his videos funny
um because we just have different senses
of humor I always like this [ __ ] yeah I
was like damn this motherfucker's
creative there's 20 million views every
week yeah and I was seeing stuff I'm
like he's just Next Level dude and he
would level up his production level
constantly yeah over time yeah and he
was so manic about creating new content
and doing stuff differently in his own
style people started biting his [ __ ]
right you know what I mean just like
people bit my [ __ ] Rants and [ __ ] I
know I know what's up yeah you know who
your daddy is [ __ ] I thought we
got fool
who's your daddy [ __ ] but um
yeah when I saw when I saw Ryan he I got
so sad when he started creating videos I
was like I don't really watch this [ __ ]
but him making videos and doing it in
the way that he did it was inspiring to
me and now he just twit does twitch and
I'm like [ __ ] like we lost another one
and then I see Kev coming over here you
know trying to address like the 88
Rising kids right right you know and
shaming your head and doing blonde
listening to his music I'm like dog this
music's bad like it's not good the
beat's [ __ ] dope because you have
dope producers but you are not very good
at this you gotta sit with us and be a
part of the culture and then maybe
figure out what your lane is right hello
my lovely genius farts it's smooth sack
summer and if you have pubes on your
balls you're a piece of [ __ ] just to let
you know
with manscape you don't have to deal
with those pesky pubes as summer comes
to an end and we enter fall keep your
boys clean and fresh just in time for
fresh ball fall baby you ball-haired
[ __ ] listen the manscape performance
package 4.0 has everything you need to
keep your sweet sack in check inside
this package you'll find that a
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
bald deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies just like the
boxers holding up that freaking droopy
ass ball sack baby let's go I love my
manscape and let me tell you something
my [ __ ] the forest is deforested just
like this Earth
get 20 off plus free shipping with code
genius at madscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code genius
at manscape.com keep things smooth and
fresh as we say sayonara to smooth ball
summer and enter fresh ball fall
I only say this because I've been doing
been doing music for a long time even I
haven't figured that [ __ ] out so when I
heard his music I was like Jesus Christ
this sucks you know I mean I'm sure a
lot of people feel it the same way once
you went from uh vlogging to podcasting
oh yeah for sure and I had to figure out
my Niche and figure out my way yeah when
I first started podcasting too I I
listened to those episodes I don't like
any of them and even now when I listen
to my podcast I'm like oh you could have
said that differently you could have
explained this a little more you could
have uh slowed down the way that you
slow you're talking a little too fast
which is how I normally speak but you
know I'm making these adjustments and
I'm finding my way and when I first
started doing podcasting
um I was so focused on trying to be like
other podcasters right right oh Bobby
Lee does it this way Joe Rogan does it
this way
um if I don't do this and I won't Garner
this type of audience well [ __ ] those
that audience yeah find your audience
talk about the things that you want to
talk about because when you try to force
yourself into this narrative that you
don't really believe people can sense
that type of [ __ ] yeah I mean people ask
me like dude how do you sit there and
just talk for hours and I'm like David
and I without cameras rolling for four
hours dude like we just talk and talk
and talk we're just natural gift of God
we just [ __ ] talk yeah and I think
it's because we also have like this
weird personality where we kind of
overthink things and it's good to talk
about it with somebody yeah
do you understand what I'm going through
yeah it's good to have somebody that
fills you yeah then you bounce off of
somebody else like finding your own
identity in this space is so difficult
right
um and to go back to somebody like Gabby
Hannah and Yousef you know I I saw these
young people who
got caught up in trying to please
everybody yeah if I don't if I do this
video if I title it this way people
won't watch my stuff they've never
really got none of these creators
created for themselves oh dude you know
being the con I was always the guy
behind the scenes that was helping make
content for other
um you know YouTubers and such and to
hear them speak about how obsessive they
were like dude I got like 10 000 less
views than the last week I'm like bro
yeah you still got hundreds of thousands
but then they really feel for that yeah
you know they really wants to sell them
they were driven by the Numbers must go
up the numbers have to go up they need
more they need more you can even ask Ed
I've never ever ever said that I always
go dude this video was so fun yeah this
video was dope posting ghost and yeah
and then there were times like oh like
we'd see it like we had so much fun
filming this it didn't get as much views
but then we still remember how much fun
it was yeah and I still love that video
the most there was some [ __ ] dog
sometimes I would watch my sketches I'm
like how did I write this this is really
good no I'll look back like how did I
edit this yeah how did I filmed this
like oh [ __ ] dude we did this really
funny sketch with uh here's another
person I want to give a shout out to is
uh Cassie ho Cassie ho is a boss [ __ ]
dude like the Verizon 4G latte and you
have to realize too you know some of
those jokes were Edge jokes
those were adds jokes like a lot of
people uh we talked about this story too
and that this story came into this it
was the totally joke right that's that's
Ed's joke like there's some funny [ __ ]
that we collabed on that we thought
about on the spot yeah and we found that
up because I mean you you took your time
out of the Lord to fly up to Seattle to
film this skit and then we've connected
Justin and we're like oh [ __ ] we're the
same [ __ ] ill dude yeah like we
understood each other even when I text
you hey man I gotta edit this this way
bring this scene up here because story
wise and then you're like I trust you
yeah and that's all I need to hear do
you know how many people I [ __ ] beef
with because I wrote it this way it has
to be this way and it doesn't [ __ ]
work and it could be fixed in the edit
but they're so [ __ ] caught up with I
wrote this this is my project thing like
I'm trying to help you make better then
it just tells me you don't trust me yeah
you know then we're not gonna do well in
the future together and we don't we end
up not working together yeah you know
but then they constantly see us work
together and they might be wondering why
couldn't he do that for me because maybe
we're not cool you're just not friends
or maybe you just didn't allow for
somebody to critique your stuff and
allow the changes that needed to be
there yeah I'm not on the video creative
side like I don't have that like I I'm a
jokes guy and sometimes when I write
these scripts I'm so focused on the
jokes I don't think about structure and
so when the structure is [ __ ] up and
somebody who does structure tells me
like hey this might not work why not
just try it let's just see yeah let's
just see and it might be better and most
of the time it was yeah
if it comes out better and you could see
you just have to like get over it it's
hard for me to imagine That's How Strong
an ego is yeah it's just an edit it's
not like cutting it and putting it on
the floor it's like moving it around
that kind of stuff sometimes yeah it
hurts to put [ __ ] on The Cutting Room
floor but sometimes it only makes the
video better like you know one of the
things I learned from Ed too early on
was like sometimes I would get like so
stuck up on the joke that I really
really wanted in the script but
sometimes you could just you have to
take it out because it doesn't make
sense yeah and we had to pull things
from certain scripts like I can't
remember one specifically right now but
I remember you had to pull like a couple
of jokes I really wanted it in but I
looked back and I was like it just
doesn't make sense and I just took that
joke and I used it another sketch yeah
it doesn't have to be in there like the
the thing was really okay
I've never really talked about this on a
podcast right only because I love and
respect these guys so [ __ ] much but
you guys understand that you know as
somebody who's a content creator I do
have opinions about other people's
content and other people have content uh
opinions about mine like
it is
always been really hard for me to like a
lot of Wong Fu sketches right
only because stylistically they were so
different from me also too but there was
a lot of like pitfalls that I saw in the
way that they would write yeah and it
was stuff that I was learning through
writing classes and everything else like
and
I've so much expose
right right and it's something that used
to always and we always talk about this
right it was like show don't tell
and I feel like with them sometimes too
when I used to watch their content and
I'm not sure about now because I haven't
seen this stuff in a long time was that
they kind of fell in love with the idea
of not trusting Their audience to be
smart enough to understand what's going
on without telling them and it would
hurt me sometimes and I'm like your
audience is smart enough they get it I
would see things that they would do
um specifically their I I I watched um
recently it was like never before
strangers something like this Fingers
Never Before again or something like
that
right which was the series that was
really really popular earlier on
um that they did it with uh Kathy Nguyen
amazing adorable I love that girl to
death uh Kathy Newman and Phil where
they were in this like uh relationship
thing right and they did a re-up of it
with them in the future one of the
funniest things that one of my friends
said
about when when he was watching it and
he was curious he goes I want to watch
some of their stuff I was like hey these
are like really prominent people in the
Asian Community like they're one of the
people that I respect so much because
they're still doing short films which
people [ __ ] forgot about yeah and
they still create short films whether I
like or dislike it doesn't [ __ ]
matter they're doing something that I
really really [ __ ] with and I respect
them so much for it
and it was a scene in the in the first
episode of of that Series where Phil is
fighting with Thea Frampton right and
they're talking about how hard these
relationships are and he was like why
don't they just show the fight
was it just Exposition next position and
like we had a fight and then voice over
uh it's like how come they just don't
show the fight I was like exactly he
goes honestly watching them do like 30
cut scenes of them arguing and fighting
and falling in love this looks like a
Valtrex commercial this fool sent me an
edit and he put Valtrex on the bottom of
it
and I [ __ ] died laughing he goes this
looks like he told her that he has
[ __ ] herpes after the fact that she
got herpes and now they're fighting
about it yeah and since then can't see
can't unsee it yeah I can't unsee it
and he he pointed something out it was
like there's too much expose for stuff
that they're already doing well and the
problem with that I saw in that in that
in that series was Expose and then they
would show it I'm like you didn't need
the expose you could have just showed it
all this stuff could have been cut out
you could have cut all this [ __ ] out and
it was good enough as it was yeah but
you don't trust your audience enough to
be smart enough to see human interaction
and see what's going on through dialogue
and action yeah you have to tell you
have to force feed them this information
yeah I think it could be a problem too
with a lot of creators because I I have
people try to [ __ ] I don't know film
explain it to me like you have to expect
your audience to be dumb like you know
you gotta you gotta give them more
respect than that they're smarter than
you think yeah I mean like we're just
talking about nope like no like he
doesn't have to you know tell you
everything he he wants the audience to
be smart enough to look into it re-watch
it you know and and and and
um you know think about it think it
through or whatever uh I I don't like
having to dumb down the content you know
just by assuming everyone else is stupid
yeah you know but it's an expression of
you and and who you are and if you
change it for a dumb audience then your
content is then dumb yeah yeah because
I'll give you an example right
how annoying is it like when you see uh
like for me this is very annoying let's
say a couple is fighting on scene right
and earlier that day within the scene
she was showing microaggressions right
the way that she would they were at the
grocery store they would you know
[ __ ] she was slam [ __ ] into the cart
or whatever whatnot right but then it
cuts to a scene of a of an expose saying
like
my wife was angry he's like okay I know
I just saw it in the previous scene I
don't need to see it here it's like you
know last week that time in the blah
blah blah blah and you say it instead of
showing it like what we we didn't know
about that and he's like you just did
this last week it's like we we need to
see that yeah we need to see it that's
that's the part thing that gets you
really invested and that's the stuff
that you could relate to you don't
always have to tell people these things
your audience is a lot smarter than you
think listen if people could somehow
follow the Marvel Universe from every
[ __ ] film that has come out now to
every TV series they could figure out
this out yeah right and also too the
enticing thing about short films too is
having to figure it out like what is
this what is this director or what is
this DP or what is the writer trying to
tell me right now and there's all these
Easter eggs that you kind of piece
together that makes you feel something
that's why the the most basic basic
thing in film is what show don't tell
yeah you have to give it towards the
audience you know who's gonna put it on
again and sit through it and re-watch it
and and pick up the little things that
they missed the first time yeah people
watch Chris Christopher Nolan films are
crying out loud yeah I'll I watch
Tennant over and over and over and again
until I could get it you know and that's
what it takes but some people see it
once and I don't like it and they don't
want to okay fine I'm not gonna convince
you to sit through another three hours
of this [ __ ] and watch it again yeah
that's up to the person who is
passionate about his work to sit through
it and watch it again because his all
his films have a rewatch ability yeah
effect to it and also too there's you
know just just to go on a little bit of
a tangent I think what I also dislike is
you know being a part of this space
sometimes is people feel like I always
have to you have to support everybody no
I don't creating art you're hurting the
Asian Community you have to support hey
you're hurting me I'm in the name how
about that what about me yeah you're
hurting me all the time
10 types of Asian girls you're hurting
me yeah we're we're
[Laughter]
hurting me so bad yeah dude I mean like
when when we are trying to represent
ourselves too like we are also giving
our perspective but then yeah with our
creatives that try to blanket all of us
together and say hey this is for all of
us
an Asian American thing it's like dude
that movie was Chinese as [ __ ] you know
and and so it was like hard for us to
get on that level like we get so much of
it you know but at the same time like uh
what what we took away from it was the
Chinese identity and saw it as a film
and people were upset at us for
critiquing it as a film yeah and like
like I said we're I'm always going to be
hyper critical about a community that I
care about the most right because you
know we want you know we call it Asian
Excellence like I'm I'm looking for that
type of [ __ ] yeah whether it's in film
whether it's in anything else and you
know so yeah I'm gonna talk a little
[ __ ] about it but I'm also going to
celebrate a lot of the great things
about it like I like I just said people
won't allow me to critique other Asian
content creators people could take my
[ __ ] all the time and I take it on the
[ __ ] chin yeah you do I hate half the
videos I create I hate 90 of the videos
I create after I'm done with it but what
happens you know an aftermath you make
better content yeah because you take in
the the [ __ ] that makes sense like from
someone you respect that critiques your
stuff you know but then you're not being
like an egomaniac about it and be like
well [ __ ] you I'm gonna make just the
same thing over again exactly right so
then you're not making anything better
like nothing is supposed you're not
allowed to touch anything just because
this person has the same face as me like
what the [ __ ] is that about like I don't
agree with that at all like if you want
to have a strong Community you should be
around other creators who will love the
[ __ ] that you do but also like give you
like the people that you respect should
be also allowed to critique it because
they're in your same space and you also
respect their opinion so you can't say
you respect their opinion but you're
like don't ever talk about the [ __ ] that
I do then why'd you create art for the
public to see if you didn't want people
to judge the [ __ ] that you create then
don't [ __ ] put it out and
I'll tell you this story too
Ed and I did a funny video
it was a parody of a Wong Foo okay it's
so funny because I just rewatched it two
days ago how funny is that it's
literally one of these funniest yeah
like I rarely get to look back at some
of my videos and just go damn that's
funny by the way once again in the
fashion that we do things I wrote that
the day before yeah I contacted
everybody to be in the video and they
were in and we got Jay Park in it yeah
he just happened to be in town dude you
found it you wrote the part for
dumbfounded like describing him and he
we show he showed up wearing exactly
exactly how we described him dude shout
outs to dumb literally he did something
so small in that that made me cry
laughing was like when we were in the
room
dude that [ __ ] makes me cry laughing
every so well gum did such a [ __ ]
amazing job yeah right Julie Zahn
amazing [ __ ] Jace Ace amazing Jay
Park [ __ ] killed it yeah right well
that video was a parody of a Wong Fu
sketch what was it what was their sketch
called the last it was called the last
Circle The Last Resort The Last Resort
right and I remember just laughing my
ass off writing this [ __ ] and I hit up
Julie everybody the day before and they
all came through everybody killed their
part well
Phil was not happy about it yeah came
through the grapevine through our mutual
friend he was like hey uh apparently
Wesley liked it
when I actually saw him later an event
he was like dude you shot that really
well I'm like dude I emulated with you
yeah because you shot it yeah so we just
bit your guy's [ __ ] you know shot for
shot and it wasn't me making fun of Wong
Fu stuff I just thought of something how
funny would it be if it was this it was
a parody it was flipped and
you know through the grapevine I heard
that he he was he was hurt by it which I
understand because it came from his
heart well guess what this also came
from my heart
it came from like a heart like when we
were writing that far uh some the script
the date like before it was like um the
the part when you said uh that was
yesterday because that's something that
happened to me yeah a girl was telling
me how she went on a bad like
Valentine's Day date I was like we were
seeing each other and you ghosted me on
Valentine's Day are you [ __ ] crazy
yes look we wrote that part in you know
yeah like it was also from his heart but
and the my critique of that was listen
if you don't want people to judge your
work then don't show it to people
you cannot control what people think
about your stuff yeah it is only your
job to make sure that you create
something that you care about that you
thought was good or maybe sometimes
you're just creating it because you
wanted a paycheck but whatever the
purpose is that is what you can control
everything else is all for the birds
people can hate it people can love it
that's why I've said it on this podcast
before I don't care what people say
about me on Reddit I have said the
things that I've said and it hurt their
feelings it makes them mad who I am
upsets who they are
whatever that's they're right that's
their right to feel that way right right
I get it I understand we have the
ability to filter some of these words
and comments as well because if it's
just some [ __ ] guy like Rando like
and they haven't they don't have
anything to show for you know to
critique our stuff then I don't have to
listen to it yeah you know but like of
course when like I I did this thing for
uh Jessica Chastain's Instagram where it
was like a look-alike thing because she
looks like all these other Hollywood
redheads and then taika waititi
commented
boom made my [ __ ] career like holy
[ __ ] this guy I look up to likes my
stuff I mean he didn't say it directly
to me commented on her Instagram yeah
but yeah it means a lot to me but if he
said yo this is [ __ ] and I have to I
take a good look at myself if someone I
respect doesn't like my work yes it
hurts but am I gonna start dming him and
then start talking [ __ ] about him on
Reddit yeah dude it was a passing
comment yeah 100 and also too I never
thought that he would have an issue
listen I Love Phil I think Phil's one of
the dopest
um but at the time I didn't think that
it would have been a problem right and I
still don't think it's a problem
especially because was it the last was
also 300 500 Days of Summer or whatever
it was literally a cut scene from 500
Days of Summer so you already were
inspired by something else right and now
I'm inspired by you
and their video got a few more million
views after mine and nobody ever said
that oh that their video was trash yeah
it was just said that mine was funny I
mean I could see where it would be
offensive if you ended up getting more
views than his yeah but no his has way
way more views and the Wasabi guys they
got a [ __ ] ton of views because they did
the same thing too yeah you know like
there was a lot there's a lot of Wong Fu
parodies out there but then it was a
weird kind of vibe to be like oh you're
mad at us though yeah yeah yeah yeah and
I wasn't upset at Phil for being upset I
mean he's he's a look at the content he
creates he's a lover boy yeah you know I
get it and I come from the world where
people are just all [ __ ] yeah right
there are sometimes too where I'll we'll
text within our group so we'll be saying
some [ __ ] and we're like hey are we
[ __ ] or is this [ __ ] [ __ ] black
and then you know my friend's wife was
like
uh you guys are [ __ ] for sure but
that's whack yeah yeah so you know I
understand we're just we just come from
two very different worlds and look I I'm
always gonna support if anybody talks to
me about Wong Fu right I'm like they go
if they ask me like do I enjoy their
content I have to be honest because I'm
not gonna lie about it right but I
always say but look those dudes are
doing [ __ ] out there that a lot of
people aren't doing which is Pioneers
they're Pioneers they're creating short
films that people are afraid to do now
because it doesn't get views they still
do stuff that they're passionate that
they care about and that right there is
the most respectable thing about them
but people get caught up on the yeah but
I didn't like that what the [ __ ] like
yeah dude you asked me if I liked it you
asked me that was your question you
asked me of course I'm gonna answer
honestly I'm not gonna you know gas them
up because I feel like I have to but
then like if you make that light like oh
it's so good and then that person
watches it and they don't think it's
that good then you look like the [ __ ]
yeah and I refuse to be those people on
Instagram who are celebrating these
Asian American actors that they've
openly talk [ __ ] about
to me you know it's like you cannot do
that you are you are way whoever you
think that they are you're way worse
than them unless they're doing the same
[ __ ] that you're doing it's as if they
think in their mind that actor is
waiting for them to comment some
compliments on their thing and if they
don't then they're gonna assume that
when maybe that happens I think a lot of
people get in their head yeah
oh my God my sister my brother shut the
[ __ ] up dude you are trash man and you
already know you already know I DM I'm
like fake you're being hella fake what'd
you say last week they just laugh hahaha
LOL I was like you know the next time I
see I'ma [ __ ] rip you about this [ __ ]
I was like you better keep your [ __ ] a
hundred like you better the next time
you see it you better say the [ __ ] that
you were saying to me about them in
front of their face the the Blue Tech
changes people man bro I said this
before and I'm literally serious about
this where I
had a conversation with a friend who um
openly was talking [ __ ] about other
actors saying like oh these people they
change once they get super [ __ ]
famous well this girl was acting a
little different too right like the way
that she was talking to me said oh let's
do lunch and they wouldn't hit me back
up or whatever I'm like I never asked
you to go out to eat you hit me up yeah
right but that's just the Hollywood
thing to do and so when we finally
grabbed lunch
and there was a few other things that
led up to this and I was like Hey listen
like you're a friend you know I
appreciate you all this stuff but you're
[ __ ] whack and they're like why why
like what did I do what I do we're
laughing I was like I'm laughing too
right because it's funny I'm like you
know what you would you what I found out
about you I was like this is who you are
you were talking [ __ ] about other people
because you wanted to be a part of that
group not because you disliked what they
were doing is that you weren't a part of
the group that got to treat other people
like that and that's you right now I was
like don't ever pull this Hollywood
[ __ ] on me don't ever be like let's
do lunch you've never said let's do
lunch [ __ ]
you know what it used to be before are
you hungry you want to go grub yeah
let's do lunch don't ever say that
phrase to me but the real ones will come
back to you because they can rely on you
on your reality check yeah that they
want to get grounded and then they value
your friendship for your honesty yeah
right and then there's the ones that
like oh David was mean to me and then
they just go disappear they don't want
to talk and by the way too like I'm
saying this with like very with tech you
know I'm sure shortening the stuff this
was a long conversation right and look
they apologize they get it it's like I'm
getting caught up in my [ __ ] it's like
yeah you're getting caught up in your
[ __ ] dude like I know you could you
could do your Hollywood [ __ ] with
your Hollywood friends I'm a [ __ ]
podcaster YouTuber right and I own a
matcha franchise you know I've been to
Sundance yeah I've done things you know
what I mean but you know my point in
this space too like I've always said it
too is like listen I want to be a part
of the space but if I'm not I don't care
right because I don't really care I
could do this podcast forever I could do
short films at only like 10 000 people
see and I'll still love it I'll love it
every day because it makes me feel good
so when I when I see this like type of
behavior and you guys too like if you
have friends like that in a in a very
nice and cordial way call them out on
their [ __ ] because you would want them
to do the same for you yeah right I've
been called out by my friends about
certain things too where sometimes where
I say things really crass
um because sometimes I forget to to flip
my brain right because sometimes I'm in
a group of comics and we [ __ ] on each
other 24 7 and I forget I'm not in front
of group of comics and then I'm just
destroying human beings and then they're
like April you gotta [ __ ] calm down
that [ __ ] was hella rude I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm in the wrong group and then I
have to go around I have to apologize
and that's on me but thank God I have
friends who can tell me that [ __ ] it's
like bro that [ __ ] was a little [ __ ]
up I'm like yeah you're right man my bad
man I I for some reason thought you know
I could make fun of you like your Jason
Chen and you're right
and we talk about this is because like
we need to be real we need to live in
reality like social media is this other
universe that people like it slips into
our real world and like we we need
reality checks we need to [ __ ] keep
ourselves like bound to this earth bro
you know how [ __ ] detached some of
these young kids are or not young kids
uh young kids who who are desperate to
be famous because it's not all young
kids these specific group of kids
a buddy of mine stand at Comic when he
got invited to an influencer event and I
DM them like what the [ __ ] are you doing
there he goes bro
this is a life experience I need to
experience and throughout his whole
story he's making fun of these kids and
they don't even know it
he's like dude I'm out here just [ __ ]
you know what I mean living life dude
living life on the edge man they don't
want us to succeed they want us to fail
and these kids like yeah [ __ ] yeah
and he's like yeah and he turns around
he goes [ __ ] losers they don't even
understand I'm dying laughing at his
stories but they don't even know yeah
they they think he's for real yeah it's
like
you don't even know what's real or not
yeah like you just saw somebody
recording a camera and you wanted to be
a part of it because he could probably
be famous I mean and you see those
people who have the the red light face
right the red light being because old
cameras used to have a red light when
it's recording and once you see a red
light boom different personality you're
everything is amped up to the tens you
know like hey guys we're out here yeah I
mean you see that when you go out to eat
with a bunch of girls and they're like
okay I'm gonna do a boomerang
cheers let's do that again
cheers
[Music]
so one of the trippiest things when I
first saw was uh I was at this club
event and this [ __ ] this was one
dude that was just I'm not saying his
name but he was like yo we out here we
living man my life's a [ __ ] movie
turns Away really quiet starts posting
it sits down he's just quiet not talking
to anybody yeah I'm like bro this is a
[ __ ] trip man yeah and and like even
like reality shows I was I was a part of
a few reality shows you know and I've
seen them do multiple takes of what's
supposed to be reality you know people
still don't understand that reality
shows aren't reality there's a producer
out there they still so I'll give you an
example I was me me and Tim were
supposed to be a part of a reality show
a very famous one right yeah but they're
they they liked our chemistry that what
we do with dudes behind the foods and
send foods and also on the podcast that
we have um
so they have a fill out a questionnaire
and they're asking questions because I
know about reality TV you know I've I've
been on non-scripted [ __ ] and they're
asking questions that you could tell
they want to see what the dirt is that
we have on each other right things that
we dislike about each other what would
cause drama on the show yeah but Tim and
I never fight yeah yeah you know I
rarely ever fight with any of my friends
yeah right so we're just saying nice
things about each other and they're like
the whole pass it's like see this stuff
is
like they wanted us because we have a
following but they didn't want us
because we're not combative enough right
and this is what they want they want to
destroy you guys exactly they want to
see this drama they want to hear this
like crazy friendship story but it's
like we don't have that and we're not
gonna lie about it so it's wild to think
that they'll set up a situation and they
say go right and then they might not
like it all right let's do that again
but then you're already like beefed up
about something like why would you want
to live through that yeah and they'll
tell you like hey instead of like
um
instead of trying to go there and like
like Comfort them can you like critique
some of the stuff that they're doing
wrong it's like why would I do that yeah
but it's like the reality TV shows will
do that yeah people don't understand
that at all and that's just like the
that's just a sad thing about it that's
why there's so many meltdowns on reality
TV because they're [ __ ] with their
psyche dude the girl from a Terrace
House who committed suicide oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah there was the mom is suing them and
the show's not coming back because it
was it was found out the producers were
telling her we're kind of telling her
what to say and it caused her to flip
out and it [ __ ] up her her perception
of herself I didn't know that I thought
it was her just being an [ __ ] right
but the producers had a hat in the way
that she was behaving and she couldn't
deal with the trauma that she got from
other people online people harassing her
and then she killed herself yeah yeah
that's reality TV and on this happy note
this wraps up this episode
of The Genius brain podcast y'all uh you
catch Ed at edpark VP and you could
catch genius brain every Sundays at 12
p.m check out the clothing line
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y I've been seeing a
lot of people wear this [ __ ] which is
which is great and like I said the best
feeling on Earth is when I walked up to
somebody I was like hey nice shirt and
they go cool have you heard a secret
society
they don't know that you [ __ ] me hey
all right and that felt really good but
if it's out there in The Ether like that
and didn't even know then that's amazing
yes it's reached out exactly so I want
this clothing company to be like
literally in everybody's closet so uh
check it out please
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y wait for that
genius brain uh uh secret society collab
piece that we did It's [ __ ] amazing
it's taking a long time because it's a
very very complicated piece It's [ __ ]
amazing huge part of my culture
everything I love about it uh genius
print every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll see
you all next time peace peace
right now
[Music]